as a European consumer when you pay for  a product or service online or in a shop  in your home country or elsewhere in the  EU and you have rights five of these  important consumer rights are the right  to truthful advertising about the nature  of products and services and the costs  involved the right to contracts that  have clear conditions and low unfair  clauses the right to return greutzwald  online within 14 days the right to have  defective goods repaired or replaced for  free  the right to free assistance in your own  country from European consumer centers  in case of problems with a trader abroad  before you buy know your rights and use  them if anything goes wrong